Nous avons retenu notre souffle et rongé nos ongles
et enfin assisté à la première collision de protons
à l'énergie la plus haute jamais utilisée.
Applaudissements, champagne, célébration.
C'était un tournant pour la science,
nous n'avions aucune idée
de ce qu'on trouverait dans ces nouvelles données.
Quelques semaines après, on a trouvé une disparité.
Ce n'était pas une grosse disparité,
mais c'était assez gros pour nous faire sourciller.
Sur l'échelle de 1 à 10 du haussement de sourcils,
si 10 indique la découverte d'une nouvelle particule,
c'était un quatre.
(Rires)
J'ai passé des heures, des jours, des semaines à des réunions secrètes,
débattant avec mes collègues sur cette disparité,
la manipulant sans pitié avec ce qui nous passait par la tête
pour voir si elle supporterait d'être observée.
Mais après des mois de travail acharné --
à dormir dans nos bureaux sans rentrer à la maison,
des barres chocolatées en guise de dîner,
du café par litres entiers --
les physiciens sont des machines qui transforment le café en diagrammes --
(Rires)
Cette petite disparité ne s'en allait pas.
Après quelques mois,
nous avons montré cette petite disparité au monde avec un message très clair :
cette petite disparité est intéressante, mais pas définitive,
donc surveillons-la et récupérons plus de données.
Nous avons essayé d'être très décontractés à ce sujet.
Et le monde entier s'est quand même enthousiasmé.
Les journaux nous adoraient.
Les gens nous ont dit que ça leur rappelait la disparité
qui avait mené à la découverte du boson de Higgs.
Mieux que ça, mes collègues théoriciens --
j'adore mes collègues théoriciens --
mes collègues théoriciens ont écrit 500 articles sur cette petite disparité.
(Rires)
Le monde de la physique des particules avait été complètement retourné.
Mais qu'est-ce qui faisait que cette petite disparité
avait réussi à enthousiasmer des centaines de physiciens ?
Cette petite disparité était unique.
Cette disparité indiquait
que nous observions un nombre étonnamment grand de collisions
dont les débris étaient composés de seulement deux photons,
deux particules de lumière.
Et c'est rare.
Une collision ne ressemble pas à un accident de voiture.
Elle répond à d'autres règles.
Si celle-ci se fait presque à la vitesse de la lumière,
c'est dans le monde quantique.
Dans ce monde quantique,
les deux particules peuvent brièvement créer une nouvelle particule
qui vit pendant une fraction de seconde
puis explose en d'autres particules repérées par notre détecteur.
Imaginez un accident où les deux voitures disparaissent sous l'impact,
une bicyclette apparaît à la place --
(Rires)
et puis cette bicyclette éclate en deux skateboards,
qui frappent notre détecteur.
(Rires)
Heureusement, pas littéralement.
Ils coûtent très cher.
Les moments où deux photons atteignent notre détecteur sont très rares.
Et à cause des propriétés quantiques des photons,
il existe un nombre très petit de nouvelles particules possibles --
ces bicyclettes mythiques --
qui peuvent donner naissance à seulement deux photons.
Mais une de ces options est immense
et concerne cette éternelle question
qui me dérangeait quand j'étais petit,
à propos de la gravité.
La gravité vous semble plutôt forte,
mais elle est en réalité très faible comparée à d'autres forces de la nature.
Je peux brièvement vaincre la gravité en sautant,
mais je ne peux pas attraper un des photons de ma main.
La force de la gravité comparée aux autres forces de la nature ?
C'est 10 puissance moins 39.
C'est une décimale avec 39 zéros derrière.
Pire que ça,
toutes les autres forces de la nature sont très bien décrites
par ce que nous appelons le modèle standard,
notre meilleure description actuelle de la nature à sa plus petite échelle
et franchement,
une des plus grandes réussites de l'humanité --
à l'exception de la gravité, qui est absente du modèle standard.
C'est dingue.
C'est presque comme si la majorité de la gravité avait disparu.
On en ressent une petite partie,
mais qu'en est-il du reste ?
Personne ne le sait.
Mais une explication théorique propose une solution folle.
Vous et moi --
même vous, au fond --
nous vivons dans trois dimensions de l'espace.
J'espère que c'est une déclaration admise par tous.
(Rires)
Toutes les particules connues existent aussi dans trois dimensions.
En fait, une particule est juste un autre nom
pour une excitation dans un champ tridimensionnel ;
une oscillation dans l'espace.
Et surtout, toutes les mathématiques que nous utilisons pour décrire tout ça
présument qu'il n'y a que trois dimensions dans l'espace.
Mais on peut jouer avec les maths comme on veut, car ce sont les nôtres.
Et on joue avec des dimensions supplémentaires dans l'espace
depuis longtemps,
mais c'est toujours resté un concept mathématique abstrait.
Je veux dire, regardez autour de vous -- vous aussi, au fond --
il n'y a clairement que trois dimensions dans l'espace.
Mais si ce n'était pas vrai ?
Et si la gravité manquante disparaissait dans une dimension extra-spatiale
qui nous était invisible ?
Et si la gravité était aussi forte que les autres forces
si on la regardait dans cette dimension extra-spatiale ?
Et si nous ne ressentions qu'une infime partie de la gravité
et que c'était pour ça qu'elle était si faible ?
Si c'était vrai,
on devrait élargir notre modèle standard de particules
pour y inclure une nouvelle particule,
une particule de gravité hyper-dimensionnelle,
un graviton qui existerait dans une dimension extra-spatiale.
Si vous pouviez voir vos têtes.
Vous devriez me poser la question :
« Comment pouvons tester cette folle idée de science-fiction,
puisque nous sommes coincés dans trois dimensions ? »
De la manière habituelle,
en télescopant deux protons --
(Rires)
assez fort pour que la collision se réverbère
dans une dimension extra-spatiale qui pourrait être là,
créant temporairement ce graviton hyper-dimensionnel
avant de revenir dans les trois dimensions du LHC
et de se séparer en deux photons,
deux particules de lumière.
Cet hypothétique graviton extra-dimensionnel
est une des seules nouvelles particules possibles et hypothétiques
qui possèdent ces propriétés quantiques
et qui pourraient donner naissance à notre petite disparité à deux photons.
La possibilité d'expliquer les mystères de la gravité
et de découvrir des dimensions supplémentaires --
vous comprenez mieux maintenant
pourquoi des centaines de geeks physiciens ont tous perdu leur sang-froid
juste pour cette disparité à deux photons.
Une découverte de ce type pourrait changer les manuels scolaires.
Mais souvenez-vous,
notre avis, celui des expérimentateurs,
qui travaillions là-dessus était clair :
il faut plus de données.
Avec plus de données,
cette petite disparité se transformera en joli Prix Nobel --
(Rires)
ou les nouvelles données se placeront autour de cette disparité
et la transformeront en jolie ligne fluide.
On a pris plus de données
et avec cinq fois plus de données, quelques mois après,
notre petite disparité
s'est transformé en ligne fluide.
Les journaux ont décrit « l'énorme déception », les « espoirs évanouis »
et les « tristes » physiciens des particules.
À en croire le ton des articles,
on avait décidé d'éteindre le LHC et de rentrer à la maison.
(Rires)
Mais ce n'est pas ce que nous avons fait.
Et pourquoi ?
Si je n'ai pas découvert de particule -- ce qui est le cas --
si je n'en ai pas découvert, pourquoi je vous parle à présent ?
Pourquoi je n'ai pas juste baissé la tête, honteux,
avant de rentrer chez moi ?
Les physiciens des particules sont des explorateurs.
Et la majorité de ce que nous faisons est de la cartographie.
Voyons ça comme ça : oubliez le LHC pendant une seconde.
Imaginez que vous êtes un explorateur
arrivant sur une planète lointaine,
à la recherche d'aliens.
Quelle est votre première tâche ?
Tourner autour de la planète, atterrir, observer les alentours
pour chercher des signes de vie évidents
et retourner à la base principale.
C'est l'étape où nous sommes actuellement.
Nous commençons à observer le LHC
pour chercher de nouvelles particules en évidence
et nous pouvons dire qu'il n'y en a pas.
On a vu au loin cet étrange alien sur une montagne,
mais quand on s'est rapprochés, c'était un rocher.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ensuite ? On abandonne et s'en va ?
Pas du tout.
On serait des scientifiques vraiment nuls.
Non, on passe les quelques prochaines décennies à explorer,
à cartographier le territoire,
à fouiner dans le sable avec un outil de précision,
à regarder sous chaque pierre,
à creuser sous la surface.
Les particules peuvent autant apparaître aussitôt,
comme des disparités en évidence,
qu'elles peuvent apparaître après des années de collecte de données.
L'humanité vient juste de commencer son exploration au LHC
à cette si haute énergie
et nous avons des recherches à faire.
Mais que se passera-t-il dans 10 ou 20 ans,
si on ne trouve toujours pas de nouvelles particules ?
On construira une plus grosse machine.
(Rires)
On recherche à une plus haute énergie.
On planifie déjà un tunnel de 100 kilomètres
où l'énergie d'une collision serait dix fois grande qu'au LHC.
On ne décide pas où se trouvent les nouvelles particules.
On décide de continuer à explorer.
Et si même avec un tunnel de 100 kilomètres
ou un tunnel de 500 kilomètres
ou un collisionneur de 10 000 km flottant dans l'espace
entre la Terre et la Lune,
on ne trouvait aucune particule ?
Alors là, il faudrait revoir notre physique des particules.
(Rires)
Peut-être que nous devons repenser les choses.
Que nous avons besoin de plus de ressources, technologies, expertises
que ce que l'on a maintenant.
On utilise déjà l'intelligence artificielle
et l'apprentissage automatique
dans le LHC ;
imaginez une expérience de physique des particules
utilisant des algorithmes si avancés
qu'elle s'apprendrait à trouver des gravitons hyper-dimensionnels.
Et si...
l'ultime question :
Et si même l'intelligence artificielle ne répondait pas à nos questions ?
Et si ces questions posées depuis tant d'années
étaient destinées à rester sans réponse dans le futur ?
Et si ce qui me dérangeait quand j'étais enfant
était destiné à rester sans réponse pour mon existence entière ?
Alors, ça sera....
encore plus fascinant.
On serait obligés de penser de manières complètement différentes.
On serait obligés de revoir nos suppositions
pour voir si elles ne contiennent pas d'erreurs.
Il faut encourager plus de monde à nous rejoindre pour étudier la science
car nous avons besoin de nouveaux regards sur ces problèmes anciens.
Je n'ai pas les réponses et je les cherche encore.
Mais quelqu'un -- peut-être à l'école en ce moment,
peut-être pas encore né --
pourrait nous faire voir la physique d'une façon vraiment nouvelle,
et nous montrer qu'on pose simplement les mauvaises questions.
Ce ne sera pas la fin de la physique,
mais un nouveau départ.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)